bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 22 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette édition la ville de
coignières vient d'inaugurer son nouveau
pôle médical un investissement d'un
million huit cent mille euros pour
s'adapter aux besoins de la population
le député maire de versailles en colère
après le rejet de son rapport sur les
conséquences de la baisse des dotations
de l'état
comme de nombreux élus ils s'inquiètent
du recul de la capacité d'investissement
de sa commune et enfin nous verrons
comment occuper vos vacances de noël au
cours de cette édition avec nos invités
ferme de gally château de breteuil de
loisirs et services jeunesse du lion
cours et un mot de santé pour commencer
cette édition la ville de coignières a
inauguré le 11 décembre dernier son
nouveau pôle de santé
pluridisciplinaires c'était dhabi sont
qui a ouvert début novembre remplace
l'ancien centre médical situé rue des
étangs qu'ils n'étaient plus conformes
aux nouvelles lois concernant
l'accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite
un reportage de williams elle superficie
de 520 mètres carrés un parking privé de
26 places pour un coin est à d'un
million huit cent mille euros
ce nouveau pôle santé
pluridisciplinaires répond à une
nécessité de la ville de coignières de
s'adapter aux besoins de sa population
précédemment nous avions bien sûr un
centre médical et qui était situé rue
des étangs dans un ancien pavillon et
qui n'étaient plus adaptés aux personnes
notamment à mobilité réduite et qui
n'était plus conforme si vous voulez aux
nouvelles lois concernant le handicap
ce bâtiment beaucoup plus fonctionnel
bâti de plain pied au niveau
rez-de-chaussée accueillis dès son
ouverture les médecins locataires de
l'ancien centre
dans l'état actuel nous sommes deux
médecins généralistes gynécologues
en tout huit praticiens médicaux
paramédicaux c'est à dire une kiné des
podologues pour l'instant une partie du
bâtiment est encore disponible à la
location pour de nouveaux praticiens
spécialisés qui manque encore dans la
région pour des raisons de démographie
médicale
malgré la traque
évitez de ce nouveau pôle santé il ya de
nombreux besoins qui ne sont pas
satisfaits à coignières par exemple
orthophoniste par exemple étoffer
l'équipe qui n'est par exemple un
dentiste qu'il n'y a plus
malheureusement à coignières et puis
d'autres spécialités comme par exemple
ophtalmo dermato peu rhumatologue peu
dans laquelle il ya une énorme demande
qui n'est pas satisfaite
ajouté aux anciens patients de la pmi de
coignières désormais fermé de nombreuses
personnes de communes limitrophes se
rendent dans ce pôle santé qui pour
l'instant enregistre déjà une trentaine
de consultation en moyenne par jour et
nous passons à présent à la chronique
politique du mardi avec wilfrid riche il
est question des dotations
bonsoir florane ces fameuses dotation
globale de fonctionnement accordée par
l'état qui focalisent actuellement
l'attention des élus depuis 2014 le
gouvernement a décidé de réduire
drastiquement les transferts d'argent
vers les collectivités qu'il s'agisse
des villes ou des agglomérations le but
est bien sûr de faire des économies pour
renflouer les caisses c'est tout en
poussant les villes à trouver d'autres
sources de financement seulement si
c'est facile à dire c'est plus difficile
à mettre en pratique et face à
l'inquiétude des élus en juin dernier
une commission d' enquête visant à
évaluer les conséquences de la baisse
des dotations de l'état a été mise en
place
le député maire divers droite françois à
2 mazières donc de versailles en était
le vice-président son rapport devait
être publié le 10 décembre dernier
seulement ce document de 175 pages a
tout simplement été rejetée et c'est le
mot censure qui revient le plus souvent
d'autant que le rapport n'étant pas
publier il est interdit pour ceux qui
ont travaillé dessus d'en parler seuls
les auditions réalisées peuvent être
commentés car ces auditions étaient
public écoutez françois de mazières
vice-président donc de cette commission
denquête de ses auditions que nous avons
pu faire vous voyez très bien
qu'effectivement les premières
conséquences d'un baisse des recettes
des collectivités territoriales c'était
un effondrement de l'investissement
public
c'est une baisse 25 % sur les trois ans
depuis 2000 15 jusqu'à 2017 compris et
donc
c'est un problème évident pour notre
économie et c'est une cause du chômage
alors ce que dit françois de mazières
c'est donc qu'en réduisant les
subventions l'état va pénaliser les
mises
les mises en chantiers lancés par les
villes par exemple les investissements
toutes les réalisations lancé par ces
communes mais cela va même plus loin il
ya un vrai risque pour le service public
tout simplement assure françois de
mazières le député maire de versailles
et qui est plus que remonté lui qui dans
sa ville subit une sorte de double peine
à la chute de ses dotations de l'état
s'ajoutent la hausse de la participation
de sa ville au fonds de péréquation
péréquation cette contribution qui est
versé par les communes les plus aisés à
celles qui sont plus en difficulté pour
compenser à la baisse des recettes pour
versailles entre 2013 et 2017
il devrait augmenter de 17 points les
impôts il ya un moment où on n'a pas le
choix soit si vous voulez on va
augmenter la fiscalité locale et là très
clairement aujourd'hui de très
nombreuses communes sont engagés dans la
maîtrise de la fiscalité locale c'est
une demande de la population
et puis si vous faites pas
l'augmentation des impôts des communes
comme nous qui font l'objet
cette redistribution négative vous
n'avez pas tellement le choix
c'est à ce moment là soit vous endettez
ce qui est de la fiscalité âtre court ou
moyen terme ça rentre à une augmentation
fiscalité et donc que nous tirons la
sonnette hardyson on a pu faire des
efforts sur deux ans même si ces efforts
étaient extrêmement violent mais à trois
années 2010 est sain passe plus c'est
impossible
seule solution donc freiner les
réductions de ces diminutions de
dotations de l'état car cette situation
vous l'avez entendu avec françois de
mazières ne concerne pas uniquement
versailles écoutez cette proposition de
françois de mazières
notre proposition entend parlementaire
si vous voulez c'est que l'on ajourne la
réforme qui était prévu en 2007 c'est
d'ailleurs bien précis qu'on ajoute
l'augmentation de la baisse des
dotations qui était prévu en 2007 en
2010 est silencieux et le plan qui était
annoncé en 2015 vous avez une baisse
très forte des notations 2015 baisse
très forte des dotations 2007 et
nouvelle baisse en 2017
cette nouvelle baisse elle devient
qu'elle est insupportable et puisque
vous évoquiez les hausses d'impôts pour
faire face aux déserts désengagement de
l'état il faut savoir que dans certains
cas elles ont déjà été votées le
département des yvelines l'a d'ores et
déjà annoncé il y aura une forte hausse
des impôts locaux le président pierre
bédier parle d'une impasse budgétaire
sur le fonctionnement avec 4 25 millions
d'euros en moins en 2017
les conseillers départementaux vont se
réunir le vendredi 22 janvier prochain
pour le vote du budget primitif
merci wilfried on vous retrouve juste
après ce journal pour une nouvelle
édition du cpie de politique consacrée
aux nouveaux élus du conseil régional
tout autre sujet à présent le tout
nouveau burger king vient d'ouvrir dans
les yvelines après paris le 91 le 92 le
93 et même le 94 le val-de-marne les
yvelinois vont aussi avoir leur enseigne
située à l'espace saint quentin à
montigny le bretonneux
l'enseigne de 426 mètres carrés a ouvert
ce mardi matin à 11 heures pour faire
fonctionner le restaurant burger fini à
embaucher une centaine d'habitants du
secteur et les clients étaient nombreux
à avoir fait le déplacement pour
déguster le sandwich phare de la marque
le groupe heures fanny bourdillon et
mika et minéraux sont allés demander aux
nouveaux clients ce qu'ils pensaient de
cet engouement
j'étais fan ou ya une vingtaine d'années
oui effectivement
et puis bon bah monde sans voiture n'a
pas eu trop le choix maintenant
maintenant que sa roue va on est là
premier jour fidèle au poste vu le nom
qui adore et vu la foule c'est un
événement pour tout le monde avec
impatience web tous les jours on se met
à jour pour voir quand est-ce que ça
allait ouvrir et puis voilà on savait
que c'était aujourd'hui on est bien mais
ça va attirer beaucoup de monde et du
moins les étudiants 6 et les villes aux
alentours aussi vous ne pourra revenir
manger ici c'est plutôt attractif on va
dire d'avoir un gardien king dans sa
ville et nous allons parler à présent
des activités pour les vacances de noël
comment vous occupez en famille pendant
ces vacances ce sont nos invités qui
vont nous le dire en plateau ce soir
avec moi jean emmanuel charreaux
administrateur du château de breteuil
bonsoir à vous bruno cancer responsable
de la communication pour la ferme de
gally seront soit vincent couteau
responsable de la communication
aline de loisirs de saint quentin et
thomas jordi on saura vous responsable
du service jeunesse de guyancourt alors
bruno conseil nous allons commencer par
vous que nous réserve la ferme de gally
tancé la cre je ne pouvais pas me les
marchés de dérivés s'écouter c'est une
des premières années où on ouvre pendant
cette période de l'année et on propose
aux enfants de venir faire différentes
activités
mercredi 23 le matin il y aura des
ateliers pas d'ailleurs comme tous les
matins où nous sommes nous sommes
ouverts et puis l'après-midi il ya des
ateliers plus thématiques
certains jours on va faire fabriquer aux
enfants des couronnes de noël avec du
sapin des boules des plumes et autres ou
d'autres joueront leur faire faire des
petits cadres
en laine sur lequel on peut faire
différent type de motif
c'est fait avec de la laine coloraient
les enfants détermine le motif et puis
on va aller les aider à faire leur y en
a qui font des rondes et des sapins de
noël des des choeurs ont fait un petit
peu ce fonds parce qu'on veut et puis
d'autres jours bien qu'il fasse pas
encore très froid malgré que nous nous
soyons fin décembre on invite les
enfants à faire des nourrisseurs pour
les oiseaux donc c'est des choses qu'ils
ont tout simple fait avec des pommes de
pin de la grèce et puis des des graines
des grain d'orge de ganja grain dé grain
d'orge de grain de blé et qu'on peut
ramener chez soi prendre dans les arbres
de telle manière qu'ils vont faire ça
exactement c'est à dire les mésanges et
les moineaux du coup avec les
températures qui remontait ce que les
oiseaux venir quand même mais il serait
il serait quand même bien pour la nature
que la température qu'on connaît ce
qu'on connaît ces jours ci baissent un
peu parce que l'on connaît des
températures qui sont absolument pas
normal on est fin décembre et avoir un
15 degrés en journée c'est pas tout à
fait dans justement ces températures
assez douces pour la saison vous ça vous
impact ça vous fait plus de monde en ce
moment
puis plus de monde pas nécessairement
voyez il ya du monde qui vient ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on peut faire
plus d'activités en extérieur que les
autres années
il je suis convaincu qu'il faudrait que
la température baisse pour préparer une
bonne année une bonne année 2007
on continue d'avoir un climat aussi
chaud ça va avoir des répercussions sur
les productions agricoles de manière
évidente alors ce sont des activités
très familial sont pour les plus petits
à partir de quel âge on peut on fait on
fait ces activités grosso modo pour les
enfants entre 3 4 ans jusqu'à 10 12 ans
pour les plus grands il ya aussi
également les animaux qui sont attardés
gagnes tu vois bien évidemment les
animaux sont en visite libre on a plus
d'une centaine d'animaux des chèvres des
cochons des moutons et d'ailleurs petit
clin d'oeil on a lancé aujourd'hui un
petit jeu sur facebook les ferme de
gally qui vise à nommer nos deux petits
cochons qui sont arrivés la semaine
dernière
donc si ça vous dit voilà un petit jeu
concours pour trouver à deux noms pour
les nouveaux pensionnaires de la ferme
de égale y allait de loisirs vincent
couteau je crois que ce sont des
vacances un petit peu plus sportif que
vous proposez activité un peu plus
sportive
oui tout à fait on se dit qu'on va bien
manger pendant les fêtes donc vous
propose de faire un petit peu dallas
fait la bonne alternative
donc effectivement mardi prochain le 29
à partir de 14h on vous accueille pour
une initiation 10 le golfe qu'est-ce que
disc golf
c'est une activité qui joue avec des
frisbee avec des disques il faut les
lancer dans des paniers et le but du jeu
pour que ça pète disent qu'ils veulent
puisqu'ils faut réaliser les parcours
avec moins de vent c'est possible
il ya différents types de lancer parfois
s'est lancé très longue distance
d'autrefois
trois arbres entre le départ du lancer
et le panier il faut apprendre à manier
toutes les toutes les techniques les
les lancers que ce soit vers la gauche
vers la droite donc ça a lieu le 21
décembre à tous tout à fait complètement
gratuite complètement ouvert à tous
complètement accessible également
puisque c'est pas besoin d'être d'être
un grand sportif
on a deux animateurs qui encadreront
l'activité et qui accueille tout le
monde
vaut mieux prévoir des baskets puisque
vous ne sais pas quelle quelle météo on
aura à ce moment là mais est pour et
pour la base de l'esprit à d'autres le
également ça continue pendant ses
vacances
oui tout à fait ça mais rappelé que
c'est le fonds fait ça ça connaît un
grand succès cette année
le concept c'est une sorte de de chasse
aux trésors amélioré qui s'appuie sur
tout patrimoine historique et
environnemental de l'île des loisirs
donc on apprend en réalisant plein de
défis qu'on peut faire donc en famille
entre amis entre collègues aussi
puisqu'on est une version challenge on
apprend que les temps date de louis xiv
qui a des bornes marqué la fleur de lys
que la réserve naturelle nationale est
classée natura 2000 on apprend toutes
sortes de choses comme ça et c'est
vraiment très ludique à faire en famille
afin en groupe d'amis
c'est très sympa à faire classer les
autres activités est ce que du coup on
peut toujours accéder à la ferme
pédagogique je commence à faire un petit
peu se passer pour la base de loisirs
bien sûr on accepte toujours à faire
pédagogique on est en train de rénover
le chalet principal d'animation et
et on a construit un nouveau chalet pour
les bureaux donc en ce moment on à
limiter un petit peu les ateliers sur la
paire de noël malgré tout on fait donne
à manger à tous les animaux le matin
donc tout le monde est le bienvenu pour
donner un coup de main à nos animateurs
animalier pour pour donner à manger
participé au nettoyage des alors si vous
voulez retrouver toutes ses activités
sachez que va y aller bond avec les
impacts qui s'affiche juste en dessous
de l'écran il y avait une autre grande
thématique en cette fin d'année c'était
justement le compte il ya eu notamment
la fête du conte à saint quentin en
yvelines
on en reparle dans quelques instants
avec vous jean emmanuel charreaux juste
après donc ce reportage le centre des
monuments nationaux organise dans le
cadre du programme contes et histoires
des activités ludiques dans les yvelines
la villa savoye le château de
rambouillet et le château de maisons
laffitte se sont organisés pour offrir
aux enfants une façon merveilleuse de se
réapproprier ou de s'approprier le
patrimoine
regardez ce reportage de sephora namani
et camille lambert des plumes des
cailloux des bises et des coquillages
le tout assemblé par une jolie pâte à
modeler tous les ingrédients pour créer
chacun son bocal à curiosité à l'image
de rémy qui a construit un télescope ou
de mélisande qui a préféré une statue
avec des morceaux chacun avaient des
bâtons
une petite étoile des coquillages force
que j'aime bien faire des statuts faire
un petit plaisir parce que
c'est bien et comme sa bâche pour me
souvenir des choses il ya cet atelier de
création d'un beau qu'à la curiosité est
proposé aux enfants pendant les vacances
de noël au château de maisons laffitte
avant l'atelier ils sont invités à
découvrir le château et l'exposition les
chambres des merveilles avec une visite
spéciale jeune public
nous avons choisi de faire des ateliers
autour de la thématique des cabinets de
curiosité parce que nous rebondissons
sur l'idée que puisque nous avons une
exposition très intéressante sur les
chambres des merveilles et cabinets de
curiosités depuis novembre jusqu'en
avril nous allons exploiter cette cette
très belle exposition en choisissant de
faire nos ateliers autour de cette
thématique c'est l'idée qui repartent
aussi avec un petit quelque chose et
c'est vrai qu'en lien avec l'exposition
donc les chambres des merveilles on
avait pensé voilà la création un petit
peu dans l'idée d'une composition
fantaisistes ou fantastiques à l'article
bol d'eau ce qui est intéressant ici me
semble-t-il c'est vraiment le fait voilà
de laisser les oeuvres en place parce
qu'ils participent eux-mêmes à
l'exposition
cet atelier au château de maisons
laffitte s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
manifestation régionale du centre des
monuments nationaux
contes et histoires pendant les vacances
de noël programme auquel participent
également la ville ait sa voix et le
château de rambouillet beaucoup
d'activités organisées autour du compte
on pourra retrouver au sommet c'est mes
activités aux jeunes droite est un peu
différent qu'elle avait un petit peu
différent mais le château de breteuil du
futur le château des contes de perrault
puisque nous avons cette scène de compte
qu'ils sont
répartis dans les dépendances du château
nous avons le chat botté dans les
écuries par exemple cendrillon qui dans
sexe le prince charmant nous avons
barbe-bleue draps sales de chasse etc
et puis tous les jours que nous avons à
16h30 la conteuse qui accueille les
enfants et leurs parents pour trois
contes de perrault ou des comptes
athènes puisque nous aurons le dimanche
27 décembre
le dimanche 3 janvier le dimanche 10
janvier des comptes athènes compte de
lutins pour le 27 décembre et des
comptes de galettes et le pot de beurre
pour le 3 et le 10 janvier profiter
toute la journée
oui il faut il faut prévoir large
surtout que les journées sont courtes la
nuit qui tombe donc il vaut mieux
arriver en début d'après midi il y à
nîmes visite le matin de façon à 11h30
mais d'autres visites à 14h30 15h30
16h30 et 17h30 la conteuse c'est tous
les jours à 16h30
mais il faut bien prévoir une heure dans
le parc pour voir toutes les scènes de
comptes répartis un peu partout et puis
une heure pour la visite guidée du
château
les enfants peuvent également auprès des
ateliers de sophie confectionner des
petits bonnets de lutins ou d'études
fait de robes de princesses et des
masques et puis tous ces petits lutins
dans le parcours de la visite vont aider
le père noël puisque nous avons mis en
place un jeu de piste tout pour les
vacances scolaires de noël le père noël
a malencontreusement égaré quelques
cadeaux compte autour du père noël
il ya des comptes d'heuliez il ya des
gangs de lutins donc qui seront le
c'était dimanche dernier dimanche
prochain donc le 27 décembre il y aura
des contes de lutins en plus des contes
de perrault traditionnel ses comptes et
des conteuses les enfants participent
c'est vraiment il ya un échange tout à
fait à chaque fois il ya trois quatre
enfants qui sont amenés sur le devant de
la scène parce que la conteuse a besoin
d'un prince charmant et d'une
une gentille fée d'une petite princesse
qui dort aucune de repas enfin bon en
fonction du compte et puis parfois il ya
un méchant barbe-bleue qui intervient
aussi le chaperon rouge il ya toujours
quelques enfants qui s'y passe et voilà
que les enfants mais seront pas des
comptes qui vont les endormir à chaque
fois sans permission absolument pas pour
les pour les vacances noël ccd période
pour la ferme de gagner pour les loisirs
même prochaine bretagne qui représente
voilà beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
viennent beaucoup d'enfants c'est une
période importante pour vous vous mettez
vraiment beaucoup d'énergie c'est
important parce qu'on est vraiment le
château des familles pour une sortie en
famille c'est tout voilà l'idéal est en
ce moment il ya un moment des fêtes
les familles se réunissent et puis c'est
avec le beau temps que nous avons
actuellement un site vraiment tout le
monde à venir passer un après midi à
breteil voilà et puis en plus le château
a revêtu ses habits de lumière je dirai
pas ce que tout l'intérieur du château
est entièrement décoré les sapins un peu
partout toutes les cheminées sont
décorées îles extérieures et les
illuminations qui rendent le château
magnifique dès que la nuit tombe on va
enfin rejoindre associe à partir de
partir de trois ans agen tout le monde y
trouve son compte et puis les amateurs
d'histoire bien sûr retrouve le principe
de la visite c'est à dire la visite du
château
fait découvrir l'histoire d'une famille
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'histoire de france
donc quel côté histoire mais vu de façon
ludique et les personnages le seigneur
du château
et puis le côté conte de fées avec les
contes de perrault alors vous en
parrainant un tout autre sujet avec le
thomas sûrs d'y donc les services
jeunesse de guyancourt alors il ya plein
de stage quand l'activité qui sont
proposés pour les jeunes et notamment un
petit focus sur les médias je crois tout
à fait alors c'est vrai que ou encore
une fois on laisse la parole aux jeunes
et puis on se rend compte que les jeunes
ils sortent d'une année un peu compliqué
ils ont entendu parler de pas mal de
choses un peu dur
ils ont envie de s'exprimer et donc on
leur demandait un petit peu qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on fasse on fait
toujours ça avec les jeunes et cette
fois c'est la solidarité qui l'a emporté
et on se rend compte qu'ils ont une
véritable envie d'aller vers l'autre et
donc toutes nos activités ont tourné
autour de cette thématique plus âgée à
partir de 10 ans oui la jeunesse
comprise entre 11 ans et 18 ans et donc
on a vraiment de programme différencié 1
pour les 11 15 ans et un pour les 16-18
on considère que entre d'un côté des
collégiens et de l'autre les lycéens
seront pas les mêmes attentes et donc
cette solidarité qui au coeur un peu de
des stages qu'on va proposer vous l'avez
dit on s'est dit comment ouvrir la
parole si ce n'est qu' on a un staff qui
est possible à faire c'est un stage de
journalisme et or la cgt on a une
intervenante journaliste professionnel
qui vient et donc on leur donne une
carte de presse et on les fait rentrer
dans le petit peu dans un ambiance un
petit peu d'une salle de rédaction
ils vont choisir le chemin de fer c'est
à dire les sujets déterminer exactement
ils vont prendre leur téléphone contacts
et les intervenants et puis aller faire
leurs micros trottoirs les rencontrer et
puis on a cette thématique minutes
citoyenne on va traiter un peu de là tu
étais très local mais c'est hyper
intéressant et du coup ça leur permet de
décrypter l'information aussi c'est un
moyen pour eux de savoir parce qu on a
beaucoup d'informations qui nous
submerge et on sait pas trop les trier
et donc la fin quelle information doit
trier comme on regarde ces sources et
puis comment on compare ce qui est une
info valable ou pas et puis dans tout ça
comme on dit un acteur comment on prend
la parole et c'est un petit peu ça le
but c'est un peu leur apporter ce
soutien là donc j'ai effectivement d'un
côté des 11-15 ans de l'autre dès ses 18
ans le stage en essai sur une semaine on
peut encore s'inscrire
il peut encore s'inscrire c'est sur deux
semaines au monde un petit peu de
rigueur c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
les stages c'est effectivement dans le
temps et on a des activités bien sûr
chaque jour on peut venir pour des
activités manuelles et d'actions
caritatives aussi je vais venir après
met donc sur le stade journalisme c'est
vraiment l'idée de décortiquer les
médias et devenir soi-même acteurs de
d'un média local
c'est c'est à ce titre il est
intéressant pour eux et pour les donc
pour les 15 à 18 après ce stage de
journalisme y avait d'autres choses
la solidarité vraiment transverses dans
les actions qu'on a proposé donc on va
faire des stages donc journalisme on l'a
dit avec eux aussi des actions
caritatives dont on comprend son
téléphone on appelle les associations du
coin on a un répertoire d'une centaine
d'associations
on va les appeler en leur demander
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire nous en tant
que jeune pour vous aider et ça peut
aller du colis la distribution de
nourriture à des sources très concrètes
pour surtout commencer à mettre un pied
dans le bénévolat dans l'associatif
c'est aussi ça la solidarité
et puis on a on a aussi la visite des
pompiers pour apprendre les premiers
gestes de secourisme ces initiations
bien évidemment un peu première approche
mais c'est à mon sens c'est assez
intéressant qu'ils aient choisi ça et
puis de respect de l'environnement donc
on a la chance d'avoir la ferme de gally
je pense que le fait d'être là aussi ça
me donne des idées entre nous mais là en
l'occurrence c'est apprendre à défendre
son patrimoine sur son environnement
faire des cabanes en bois comment on
traite le bois ensuite une fois qu'on a
fini sa voix là ce sont des choses de ce
type là et puis les le sport avec des
actions plus tôt du sport collectif
d'ailleurs aidé entraide qui va être
développé la grande nouveauté aussi ccd
soirées à thème donc notamment on va
faire venir un jeune chanteur saint
quentinois qui s'appelle tea brut pib au
c'est un chanteur qui commence à percer
les connu justement un petit peu et qui
va faire un concert le tronc elle me
sens et ça exactement le même quand le
30 décembre et bien là on peut
s'inscrire aussi c'est sûr entrée libre
entre guillemets comment alors il faut
venir au point jeunes on est jeune on
est tous aussi tué alors les actions
sont pas situés tout au point jeunes
parce que j'ai bien différentes villes
dans différents lieux de guyancourt vous
pouvez retrouver toutes les informations
sur sur le site internet alors voilà
toutes les informations sur les stages
se teinte de la ville de huy en cours il
ya les comptes au château de perrault du
sport à lille de loisirs et voilà plein
d'activités manuelles avec de la laine
et les choses très sympas avec aussi les
petits cochons donc à la ferme de gally
merci beaucoup monsieur de l'avoir
présenté de nous avoir présenté toutes
ces activités pour les vacances de noël
et comme chaque année avait lieu les
traditionnelles ferry de trappes on
reste à noël samedi des centaines de
personnes ont fait le déplacement à
l'hôtel de ville pour profiter des
spectacles et activités organisées par
la mairie une après-midi sous le signe
de la convivialité à laquelle étaient
conviés les habitants de la commune
ainsi que ses alentours
regardez ce reportage est signée camille
lambert
vous l'avez peut-être reconnu l'hymne à
la joie ouvert le spectacle de la
maîtrise ap msq à l'hôtel de ville de
trappes le temps d'un samedi les locaux
se sont changés en féerie de noël un
moment de partage traditionnel année on
se retrouve dans l'hôtel de ville pour
boire des chocolats chauds manger des
confiseries faire des activités en
atelier avec les services enfance
jeunesse sport des centres sociaux le
père noël à me fait le déplacement pour
l'occasion
les enfants se sont appliqués à lui
rédiger un mot cadeaux d'autres ont
profité des différents stands
réalisation de masques pour les artistes
en herbe mais aussi atelier maquillage
pour les plus coquets
un papillon moi j'ai chanté la couronne
une dizaine d'associations étaient
présentes pour ce rendez vous les mamans
du coeur trappe entraide et loisirs ou
encore la librairie du mille feuilles
qui oeuvre pour l'insertion
professionnelle en proposant des livres
à petit prix c'est un moment des changes
c'est aussi un moment de connaissance
parce qu'on est tous sur trappe
on se connait pas obligatoirement et
c'est important je trouve des changes et
d'associations associations et puis que
la population voit aussi bas tout ce que
la ville peut leur offrir une tradition
qui attire chaque année 5 600 personnes
pour un avant goût de noël et c'est
maintenant la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec wilfrid richy pour
le circuit politique consacrée aux
nouveaux élus du conseil régional quant
à moi je vous retrouve demain pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 le journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée